Ngày Mì sau tháng mười, hiệp hội giữ liệu quốc gia phối hợp i ban nhân dân thành phố hế,
tổ chứ công bố mạng lưới chuyên gia giữ liệu toàn cầu.
Mạng lưới sẽ đông cóp kiến thức kinh nghiệp để sốt sải pháp,
nhằm giúp chung tâm năng cao năng lực quản chiế giữ liệu.
Tối ưu à quy trình khai thác và bảo đảm ả ninh, anh toàn thông tin ở mức cao nhất.
Mạng lưới được hình thành trên nămuên tắc khốt lỗi,
tựng vệ hợp bác cùng phát triển,
mình bạc chắc nghiệp liêm chính,
khoa học chất lượng lỗi mỗi linh tục, mạng mật tôn trọng quyền giữ tư,
tôn thủ phát lượt, kết nối toàn cầu phát việp bản sắc việt.
Đến nay, mạng lưới đã có sự tăng kết thăm ra của gần tả mươi chuyên gia từ nhiều quốc gia trên thế giới,
nhiều hành quốc, khóa kì, nhật, cán ra ra.
Khóa đó, kết nối chiế tựa việc trong gọi ngoài nước,
cùng chia sẻ chi thức kinh nghiệp và sáng kính,
để thu dẩy phát triển nên tinh tế giữ liệu Việt Nam tự chủ sáng tạo vào hội nhập khu tế.